good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having an amazing day
um my day started rough already because
i woke up with a migraine
and like double down so i'll start from
the beginning please
actually i have to go back to the way
beginning i really want to start because
november 6
1991 two big [ __ ] i get confused because
you and olivia like were born like the
same year you know you're trying to age
me
no well yesterday i i'm like committed
i've restarted
atkins oh wow and so yesterday was my
first day
and they do say there is a bit of an
induction yeah
fatigue for me it's a headache so i went
to bed like knowing i was gonna have a
little bit of an atkins headache but
fine like that's what i deserve after
weeks of eating
months of eating poorly so i actually
fell asleep last night at 8 45 like i
was just so tired from
the day back and i woke up so i slept
like a whole 12 hours but i woke up at 6
a.m and i felt a migraine coming on well
no it was there
so i took my my magical pill i woke back
up at eight o'clock
and it was still there which is not
usually what happens with the magical
pill because it's
magic so i had to take another one and
it's like still sort of here
i don't know this induction flu is it's
worse than before
well i'm just feeling disoriented as
well because you and i are doing our
show about in
like 45 minutes earlier than we normally
do and that's because our duty as ants
just comes first we have a big day to
take care of today because we are
we're on ant patrol you know but like
we're on like unsupervised ad patrol
olivia
and zach are moving apartments so like
mckayla needs to be just like
looked after and that's like our gonna
be our job for the next 12 hours and i
just think that's very exciting like
her brain is like a sponge and it's in
her hands you know what should we teach
her
yeah we're gonna just show her the way
you know and that is why
unfortunately for really me because you
get to see him all the time but that's
why theo's not here today because we're
on auntie duty
and so like we can only really deal with
one of our nibblings at a time and i did
recently
learn that that's the word for your
plural nieces and nephews and i am the
queen of the nibblings it very well may
be
i don't feel comfortable around the word
it sounds wrong
i know but but that's the word the
nibblings the word is the word
the word is the word the word on the
street is that i'm the word on this one
and ever
like theo used to be my nephew and that
was it period point blank and it would
always be like in the mail
right pronouns but because now i have
magnolia
and michaela it's i can't keep saying my
nieces and nephews because i i feel like
that's also annoying you only have so
much time in the day
right so they are the nibblings and
they're the cutest nibblings
i've ever knit built on okay and i feel
like maybe that's like the cap for the
amount of times we say
nibblings on the show today today today
yeah
yeah um something i wanted to talk about
yesterday that i forgot to talk about is
that over the weekend i finally watched
bad teacher
give it up it's on netflix give it up
for the content upper
and last night i watched two more
episodes of a place to call home it's
definitely growing on me like the dachau
of it all like
i didn't see that so deep like i didn't
see that coming for myself
i just i don't want to say anything
because i want you to experience it in
the way
that bevin lee intended who's bev and
lin the writer her name comes up at the
end of it or his
i think it's a he his name comes up at
the end of every episode i'm like i know
i'm not really paying attention but
there's no characters named bevin lee
um but really quick back to bad teacher
i had forgotten who was in the cast and
to be honest when i saw that like
justin timberlake was a sort of main
character i called you because
you know there is a special corner of my
heart
for the hatred of justin timberlake like
it's a really special
special time for me and i think that he
ruins movies like and it's amazing that
that movie friends with benefits is as
good as it is and i give it all the
credit to mila kunis because
justin timberlake is the worst like he's
the worst in singing like i know i'm
offending we
we like always [ __ ] rail on justin
timberlake
but i stand by the statements and i
think that he's a terrible actor and
like him with his fake glasses in the
movie like he was just bothering me so
much
and i couldn't believe that one of your
favorite movies had justin timberlake in
it like it made no sense
and he definitely didn't bother me
because you're supposed to hate him in
the movie
whereas like in friends with benefits
you're supposed to be like oh my god
ship him and mila when it's like mila
could do better you know
yeah um so i understood and the
appearance and the mere presence of
cameron diaz and jason siegel like truly
does outweigh
um justin timberlake's presence maybe i
love the movie so much because the only
person who hates justin timberlake more
than you
is me yeah and i love the movie because
like it really sees justin timberlake in
the place that he deserves to be like
disrespect weenieland yeah the
disrespect on his name like is
there yeah and maybe i just a part of me
feels so justified
or maybe conversely maybe my hatred of
justin timberlake comes from my love of
bad teacher
because like his character maybe are so
intrinsically
tied to what's but he's not that good of
an actor
no watch yeah
no but what's his name oh i've noticed
mr i don't know
like he's such a weenie such a weenie um
the oh
now if i may dive into like a few
critiques of the film
um sure i didn't feel like there was
enough of like a really developed
storyline in terms of the love
between jason siegel and cameron diaz
like we knew they were going to end up
together but like
honestly she was like kind of me tim the
whole time and like i didn't feel like
i feel like i could have developed that
a little bit more i really feel that way
um the other way that i feel is that it
was good like i
it was very it was like a very good
movie to watch on a saturday but like
i don't know if i could ever get in the
mindset of someone whose favorite movie
it is you know
okay i just
it took a while for it to become like
for me to realize that it was a
favorite movie of mine but what would
happen is i would watch it like you know
it's on e or whatever and every time i
put it on like it brought a laugh it
brought a smile to my face
and then i always could count on it for
that and then it just became a favorite
movie like
yeah the first time i saw it i wasn't
like oh my god this is my favorite movie
of all time but just like
the joy that it brings me has solidified
that it is a favorite movie i feel like
you know part of growing up and being an
adult is identifying
those movies experiences that just like
bring you joy and like weirdly make you
laugh
and investing more in them you know what
i just i watched the other night because
it was on but i only watched
maybe 20 minutes and i had two hearty
laughs like literally i was laughing for
minutes after
cheaper by the dozen sensational
sensational movie they're on um disney
plus me and ben recently i think i need
to watch him both from start to finish
because
i was watching the first one and the
scene where the kids like take
like they make hank fall ashton kutcher
fall in the water and then they have to
take his
clothes and put them in the dryer and
the daughter
is like one of the twins is like sorry
about your pants hank they'll be dry in
no time
and as she goes sorry about your panting
they'll be during no time it's literally
the best movie
i was literally laughing so hard because
like that's the things that that's what
like that's our
we always do that with each other like
yesterday and it
makes me laugh every single sorry about
panting
my one critique of cheaper by the dozen
is
the original movie it's one of those
movies where everything goes wrong like
when she goes on her book tour and like
literally her kids just can't behave for
one [ __ ] minute because she finally
published a book she's been working on
the farm on the book
for so [ __ ] long she finally gets
published and goes to new york and she
has to come home because her kids are
acting insane and then oprah's gonna
come to the house and the kids can't
keep it together like yeah it's one of
those movies where nothing goes right
and like that bothers me a lot
but if you can look past that it's
really such a good movie it's such
a good movie i'm gonna have to watch i
was literally laughing like for
minutes after just thinking about it
it's on disney plus okay
that will be i have to add sequel i know
i have to add it to my
long list of things on my plate last
night i tried to finish wild wild
country again i stand by the fact that
it's a terribly done documentary because
it makes an incredible story incredibly
boring
but i am on the last episode but then i
fell asleep so i'll hopefully finish
that today
gotta get mariah carey's book done
redheads episode coming up soon have you
seen luis velez
the reviews so far are wonderful
so it's just an exciting time always to
be a redhead it's always the perfect
time to be a
it was never too late and it's never a
bad time and it's never too late
um we misspoke yesterday i thought that
the bachelorette was on last night but
you know what i really was
surprised and joyful that it wasn't it
is on tonight so we will be recapping it
tomorrow sorry that i misspoke
yesterday but um when it was like six
o'clock and i was looking at my tv guide
and it wasn't on there i was just like
truly overjoyed yeah so today's episode
won't be after dale tomorrow we'll we'll
have our afternoon recap show but today
we'll have a nice quick show for you
fast five everything else anything you
wanted to say before we dive in
no no other tv that i watch
so i guess we could just dive right in i
guess there's no time like the present
none um to get into the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and by the way you hear that clear
throat you want to know what that is my
rdh all cleared up wanna know what how
but letting everyone know that today's
episode is brought to you by vega vega
has one goal to help you power your
story with premium plant-based nutrition
that enables you to feel and perform
your best
learn more about how to power your story
with vega at myvega.com
toast vega is spelled v-e-g-a so that's
myvega.com
toast if you're looking to upgrade your
daily smoothie or level up your
afternoon snack
vega has you covered from protein
powders to bars made with real
plant-based ingredients
power your story with the number one
plant-based protein powder brand in
north america
learn more at myvega.com toast if you're
looking for delicious options with
nutrients to help support your immune
system vega has you covered with vega 1
and vega protein and greens
with delicious protein powders and daily
vitamins made with real plant-based
ingredients
you can nourish yourself inside and out
learn more at myvega.com
toast vig is designed to help you
rebuild your muscle post workout and
help you set yourself up for
tomorrow's training it's plant-based
vega sport their products are here to
help you power
your story pre-mid and post-workout it's
nsf certified for sport
protein powders and supplements vega
sport is here to help
learn more about all the vega products
at myvegamyvega.com
toast check it out and love it sign
on get your goods and get your goods
yeah okay first story we actually have
some nice stories today all right
kris jenner is saying that social media
is partially to blame for the end of
keeping up with the kardashians yes i
saw this
uh kris jenner spoke to a women's wear
daily beauty ink special issue and she
said when we first started there was no
instagram or snapchat
or other social media platforms the
world has changed now there are so many
media options the viewer doesn't have to
wait three or four months to see an
episode
we can give them all the information
anyone would ever want to know in real
time
social media is the fastest and most
controlled way to get the message out
i feel like that's what we've been
saying all along you know like keeping
up has always been like
delayed from reality reality as it's
happening in real time but like
i've come to like that for me like i
feel like we get the immediate reaction
on social media but then three to four
months later when
when it's not it's like there's not as
much at stake we get to know what was
really going on
i agree that kind of balance never
bothered me but i do understand how it
affects the show's rating because not
everyone is unbothered by it and not
everyone is so interested in the
intricacies
four months after it's gone down right
and i've always felt that they maybe
could have done a better job
in turning things around like if you can
get love island episodes out every day
i don't know why the kardashians
couldn't be doing a reality show in real
time i actually think that would be so
sick if like every week it was literally
the week in the life of the kardashians
um but the show's over so it doesn't
matter
yeah i think that that would i i hear
what you're saying like for other shows
that they should be a quicker turnaround
i think you know maybe they could have
gotten it down to like one month or two
months but like
a real-time week like that's they've
already they're past that in terms of
having to give that much up of
themselves you know what i mean oh of
course
like that's for us it's not gonna be
their family right now because they
don't need it but if
that actually is like an interesting
format yeah like someone else who's on
the up-and-up should do that because
like
it's what people you might get out what
you put into it but like they've already
gotten out
um they don't have to work that hard of
the kardashians uh
the new season of david letterman's my
next guest is was announced
kim kardashian's on it and she cries
apparently i think it's about paris
because he talks about paris
um not hilton the city um dave chappelle
is on it
lizzo's on it robert downey jr who like
i don't really care about but i'm
very much looking forward to dave
chapelle lizzo and kim kardashian oh
yeah me too i had seen
that kim is on it um you know my kim
google or whatever it was
yesterday was a big day for kim because
she was talking about a lot of stuff in
her interview that i don't think she's
ever spoken about
and i've watched a few of those david
letterman episodes i watched the kanye
one last season
and i know that he is allegedly like a
world-renowned interviewer but like i
was just like not vibing with him at all
like
whatsoever and so the guests are really
like some of the most famous people in
the world like i really hope
not to critique his interviewing style
it's just like not how i enjoy like
watching interviews i found it like a
little annoying and he was like talking
over people and just like
didn't really understand what the people
were talking about you know
i don't know if i'm making sense now but
it's the david letterman rubbing off on
me but you only saw the one
kanye one um and i saw one more on the
first season i can't remember who
someone's car alarm is going off outside
and i'm literally about to open the
window and be like shut up
and like drop a rock on the car that's
what the problem with outdoor dining is
in new york
it's done outdoor dining like i
literally was sitting at a restaurant
and the car next to me was
literally going off and the owner was
absolutely nowhere to be found i
like would lose my mind yeah it's it's
that sound will make you go crazy
because then
you'll hear phantom sounds and i'm like
i'm i still hear it yeah
no no i'm i'm blessed to have it turned
off but like
like if i was having dinner next to it
oh my god it was traumatizing
no but also i just saw a story in page
six that kim is allegedly planning her
40th birthday party on a private island
for 30 of her closest family and friends
so like i can't believe that's not going
to be me
i know but that will be like so exciting
to watch unfold
on social media it was 40. i know that's
something i feel like we speak about
pretty frequently i i
always forget how old not old but like
that the kardashians aren't like 25 you
know
they're 40. courtney's 40 already
courtney
um kim is turning 40 chloe's like
30 33 oh yeah no i think she's like 37
38. you know it's just like i always
forget that
yeah no i always remember but and that
makes what they're doing like even more
impressive because they're
so relevant and i think that they're you
know changing what it means to be
a woman in their 40s i oh a hundred
percent chloe's 36
yeah i definitely um they change like i
could literally talk about them all day
and what they've done for society like
i think they've changed what it means to
be a woman in your 40s i think they've
changed
you know what it means to be a curvy
woman like i think they've literally
changed the frontier of beauty
science fiction like literally [ __ ]
everything yeah
i agree okay next story um some sad news
about a man that we love
jeff bridges reveals he has been
diagnosed with lymphoma and is starting
treatment
this is a [ __ ] terrible story i love
jeff bridges love him and you know who
loves jeff bridges
america and we never have needed someone
we can all like agree on more we've
never needed that more
yeah the oscar winner revealed the news
on monday night on his twitter account
writing
as the dude would say new [ __ ] has come
to light i've been diagnosed with
lymphoma
although it is a serious disease i feel
fortunate that i have great term
i have a great team of doctors and the
prognosis is good i'm starting treatment
and will keep you posted on my recovery
um so i mean it's so upsetting it's very
upsetting but our prayers and well
wishes are with him
and i think he has the support of so
many behind him and i hope that
he has a speedy recovery i really do
okay on the count of three
say your favorite jeff bridges movie
without thinking three
two one stick it yeah yeah i don't know
if everyone would consider like the
gymnastics rom-com that he did
like weirdly 15 years ago um their
favorite jeff bridges movie because i
know he's been in a lot of like
important films but
stick it is you know what that's on the
list of content uppers
we need to really create a master list
like a google doc between us just
because we keep remembering here's my
master list
stick it yours is bad teacher i think
queen latifah's beauty shop is a must to
be on there
she's not that oh yeah she's the man
she's all that's good too but she's a
man
uh oh also queen latifah's just right is
also a great movie comments
oh and also last holiday okay literally
just queen lativa's like catalog of
films yeah um
hairspray hairspray is a content upper
even though it's like kind of a sad
movie
because it like deals with serious
issues it's still like the music is it's
impossible not to dance too
no and also like by the end you are up
yeah because you're on the right side of
history yeah
i would put grady showman on there too
you know i have to have a viewing of
greatest showman soon i think it's been
like a year since i last watched it
high school musical uh yes twilight
we'll make a list yeah i'll put it on
our instagram but these are the jeff
bridges movies that are most popular big
lebowski
crazy heart true grit heller high water
iron man
tron starman seabiscuit
you know what's funny is like i was like
i'm so i love jeff bridges so much
and besides seabiscuit i've not seen one
of those movies i know me too but no i
like we need to get to the ones um
we also need that are like less popular
because those are the ones that we like
we also i think like
need to watch the big lebowski i think
it's like an important movie
there's a few movies that i've never
seen that i think i need to saving
private ryan
the big lebowski um the one where tom
hanks like falls in love with the
volleyball in the ocean
wilson castaway castaway those are three
movies i've never seen you cast away
and i just feel like you need to see
them and i will see them at some point
but i kind of like being the girl who's
like never seen the big lebowski you
know
i've never seen it i've never feel felt
compelled to see it
and i don't think i ever will see it
what were the other movies
um oh my god there's so many out now i'm
on his imdb but i'm trying to find the
ones that we like
like the stick it genre yeah chicken's
so good i feel like stick it isn't even
on his imdb he probably had it scrubbed
because he was embarrassed
kingsman the golden circle oh oh yeah
he's part of the kentucky crew
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he's great
kingsman that's also a content upper
oh for sure when is the sequel coming
out
i don't know i hope that they wait till
it's the third oh yeah i hope that they
wait till theaters are open cause like i
feel like the kingsman is a movie that
is so much better experienced in a like
formal movie theater
yeah i agree well jeff ridges
we're wishing you we're sending our best
energy out there we just we know you're
gonna get through this because
it's not called gymnastics no it's
definitely not called gymnastics
um okay our next story is a follow-up to
yesterday's story because we're getting
a little bit
of more answers but also and and more
questions about the zoe 101
reunion reboot new song and also just
like a website that you register for
right also i would like to thank all the
toasters who wrote us in
sharing their ideas for for what it
could be what the reboot could be and i
would say one of my favorites was you
know
the school's shutting down like they ran
out of funds or like there's no one to
run it and zoe and the crew like get
back together
to get the school back on track okay i
like that idea
but like i think pca is like probably
like the wealthiest school you know it's
like
so fully funded the one that i liked the
most was that they go back for the time
capsule because it has been 10 years
yes that probably is what they're doing
okay no it's actually not what they're
doing
and it's um extremely confusing also
in addition to chantal jeffries like all
these other
tick tockers influencers
that's the weirdest one yeah so
jamie lynn spears posted a longer clip
caption surprise finally the legacy
continues the follow me zoe 101 see it
first experience
10 25 link in bio for tickets the
website
for the confusingly and long-winded type
of reunion special needs tickets
it's an experience they're selling 20
tickets which include admission
and the single digital download as well
as bundle packs including both the
admission ticket and merchandise ranging
from autographed cds to vip zoom access
the digital event whatever it is says
new york post is set to take place
sunday at 10 a.m pacific time welcome to
campus
come join us is what they say this is
very strange and seems like kind of
tacky to be like selling tickets and
merch for nickelodeon
so this is what i think it is because
it's still unclear and even though we've
just gotten more answers we've gotten
more questions
yeah i think it's a zoom yeah where the
cast joins and like gets all
zoomy and zoey and people can buy
tickets to watch to watch that i don't
think it's any sort of formal reboot
like we were asking wishing and praying
for
and then i guess like the new
influencers are coming in
to you know make it influentially
relevant
and i think chantal jeffrey's worked on
the new theme song i think that's the
biggest thing is that they did a
redo of the theme song which we sang for
you yesterday beautifully and i think
that that's the redo that they should be
yelling but that's just me chantelle
jeffries is a dj
yeah in addition to being an instagram
girl yeah
and she's eating the chicken smoker and
she's what i saw on her instagram
yesterday
yes wow girl's a lot of boyfriends i'm
happy for her i'm a little jealous
yeah she has good taste too excellent
taste i agree
um the other thing i wanted to say is
yesterday i did warn you on this show
that uh paul butcher who played dustin
her little brother
was really acting out on tick tock and i
posted some of the tic tacs on our
instagram and
i wanted to know what you thought of
that what was that reaction how did you
feel
my reaction was utter shock
and also shock and
it's hard to say i was truly rendered
speechless because i know that you told
us about it
i did i warned you but you didn't like
you really didn't
say i didn't say i didn't you didn't
warn us
you didn't warn us you didn't warn me
that you would be posting two of them
well you know what they and i looked
into it
i just he's like one of the maybe five
people who is always going to be a
little brother
you know yes there's some people who
just never grow up to see a little
brother
posting sexual tic talks like that it's
really shocking you know
and then i looked how up how old he is
and he's youri
he's 26. how would you feel if zoe 101's
little brother was your
age i thought it was you walking through
the door
oh my god oh my god oh my god
bailey chutney um
no i know i just i thought it was
important that the world see those tick
tocks and i'm sorry that
you were kind of collateral in that but
that's the job i chose to do and i don't
think it would be right if i didn't do
it
100 100 of the time and i don't think
he's
involved in this reboot and i do i know
i don't i didn't see his name
oh i i do because all the the cast mates
have been making tick tocks with him
oh really yeah okay but his name wasn't
in the official like tags
paul i'm not seeing a paul oh that's
crazy
i feel like he doesn't want to be
america's little brother anymore
no not big brother now no he's daddy
jackie that's daddy to you but no by the
way his tick tock is very like zoe
in addition to being pornographic it's
also very zoe 101 friendly like he's
always like harking back to his past
i think the two of those are um
inherently conflicting
i couldn't agree more couldn't agree
more inherently
inherently um is the next story the one
brought to you by stamps.com
it is so let me just wrap up this thing
i was so nervous so that we can get to
that one
so in conclusion zoe 101
reboot question mark october 25th like
link in bio
if anyone gets the tickets like let us
know it's exciting nonetheless
but confusing i feel more confused than
i did yesterday more confusing but maybe
i can help you with that because
jack it's the holiday season and this
holiday season more people will be
mailing stuff than ever before
that means the post office is going to
be busy you don't have time for that
stamps.com brings the post office and
now ups shipping right to your computer
mail and ship anything from the
convenience of your own home or office
with stamps.com anything you can do at
the post office you can do at home with
just a few
clicks plus stamps.com saves you money
with deep discounts that you can't even
get at the post office
they bring all the services of usps and
ups right to your computer
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business whether you're a small office
sending out invoices an online seller
for filling orders
or during this record holiday setting
season just sending packages to ones you
love
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
just schedule a pick up or drop it off
it's that simple
and like we said with stamps.com you get
five cents off of every first class
stamp and up to 40
off priority mail and up to 62 percent
off ups shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder over 900
000 small businesses already use
stamps.com
don't spend a minute of your holiday
season at the post office this year sign
up for stamps.com instead
there's no risk with our promo code
toast you get a special offer that
includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale no long term commitments or
contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in
toast that's stamps.com enter
toaststamps.com
never go to the post office again you
can sign me up for that
sign on never go to the post office
again it works for me
next story in some casting news that i
personally don't agree with but i look
forward to hearing your thoughts
okay dominic west ugh him again
sicko has been tapped potentially not
confirmed
to play prince charles in the crown oh
no no no no no
no no no no no no
no no wrong wait no
dominic west isn't british right like or
is he i don't know because in the
affair he's not but like he very well
could be first of all what i
love about the affair i mean not the
affair the crown is that their casting
is really on point and it's never with
mega stars who like look like princess
anna it's always kind of like smaller
british
um actors and actresses and it just
makes it more
believable because you're not like oh
that's the guy from the affair playing
prince charles
it's just a few exceptions i would say
like olivia coleman
is i didn't know her before oh okay
helena bonham carter
oh yes and you know she's the only one i
can't believe i'm like you're from
tim burton yeah whatever i feel the same
way i don't know what she does but i
know she's not
better than me yeah she's tim burton i
think she was actually married to tim
burton right
i think she might have been i think she
says muse i think so too
um you know what i mean so it's just
like i
i hate this and also i'm like hating
dominic west now because like his
messy lily james like public [ __ ]
show is really bothering me and i just
think like honestly the crowd is so
above that and you know what he might
have had the role
and i feel like he could have lost it
given what happened this week because
the crown doesn't want to be associated
with trash like that i agree with
everything you just said and i just want
to add i think my
my primary point for why i'm against his
casting is he doesn't look like prince
charles
oh of course i mean once you like and
just looking at him will be distracting
because i'll be like oh i
[ __ ] hate you from the affair the
worst show i ever watched oh i liked the
affair
the worst show and he was one of the
worst characters in like television
history and so i don't want to see that
fox in my viewing of the crown like the
crown is my safe space and i need to
get him out of here wait can i ask you a
question
so he's supposed to play the next prince
charles
yes but the season that that's coming
out november is already filmed with like
a
young ish prince charles when he's
married to diana right so they're
looking for
like an older one yes seasons five and
six
so he's probably what like 50 and 60 or
no no i think he's like
it's a or the 90s in the early 2000s
oh so it's still like the diana stuff it
is it would be covering his split from
diana which would be after like they've
had children and
right it'd probably be a new diana and
his explosive affair with camilla
parker-bowles
right okay um but it's final talks that
he's in to play prince charles in
seasons five and six of
netflix's smash hit royal drama the
crown i do hope
that um uh no like i don't i hate to
like root for someone's
failure but it's not a failure that i'm
running for i just hope that he doesn't
get this part you know
i hope he gets the next part that he's
going after a bigger one i hope the
other person who's in final talks gets
this part
no and i hope that this podcast like
lands on the desk of someone who's
important at netflix because i feel like
this is a huge mistake and like if you
could know that like
we are like a focus group and i'm
telling you i know we're right about
this like if you could avoid ruining
an almost perfect show just by listening
to some dumb podcasts like i implore you
please
send this to your boss at netflix like
please do not cast dominic west like i'm
begging you and also
like aside from our personal opinions
aside he doesn't look like prince
charles agreed and there's so many and
like also
i feel like he probably is british now
that i'm thinking about it i don't think
they would cast an american like that
honestly no i really i feel like it's
very true
yeah i could see him being british and
i'm thinking about the way he talked as
noah
and he's always like talking a little
weird so he definitely is british and he
was also just with lily james in london
he's totally british
totally um please just don't like it it
would be
a disgrace to the legacy of the crown
the show and the actual crowd it would
be a disgrace to queen elizabeth
to have herself associated with a show
like the affair
i agree you know so unfortunately it's
gonna be a no from us
but we look forward to seeing what you
do with the casting yeah we do
okay our fifth and final story is a
little zoom masturbation news
this is such a weird story it was all
over my twitter yesterday
such a crazy story jeffrey tubin was
masturbating
in front of new yorker bigwig's report
says okay i just have to say
this article is so misleading because i
for like the longest time thought it was
jeffrey um tobin
it's two o's no but the actor from um
arrested development no no he's a former
arrested development yeah jeffrey tobin
is that his name
i don't think it's tobin i thought it
was jeffrey
jeffrey tayman timber tambour yeah
yeah okay he's like from everything he
was in her entourage i literally thought
that this is about him and i'm like this
guy's disgusting this is not about him
this is about the new yorker writer and
cnn analyst jeffrey toobin
who didn't just expose himself during a
zoom work meeting he was allegedly
caught masturbating in the call
with some of the magazine's biggest
names and has been suspended from the
publication
he said i made an embarrassingly stupid
mistake believing i was off camera
i believed i was not visible on zoom i
thought no one on the zoom call could
see me
i thought i had muted the zoom video i
apologize to my wife
family friends and co-workers so when i
i mean this is like everyone's worth
nightmare first of all and when i read
the article it was my understanding that
like he was on a zoom
and then he put his like um laptop
screen like down a little bit like
almost
closing the computer which directed the
camera to his
genital area and uh people on the call
like weren't sure whether
he was like he got caught by accident or
he had moved the camera to show his
penis like
which is so disgusting honestly you know
what i think it was i think
he probably thought by putting the
camera down like he was turning it off
like yeah
so this is like an old person zoom like
zoom dilemma
yeah well to be honest i mean
justice for everyone else it said two
sources said that at one point it looked
as if tuban was taking another call
and lowered his camera and that's when
they saw him getting to work on himself
it was unclear what if anything others
on the virtual call saw
so i think what happened was like he was
getting a call probably like facetime
like about to have face time sex and so
he lowered his computer camera
so that they wouldn't see he was on
another call right not realizing that
the other thing he's
about to do is so much worse yeah than
him looking disrespectful on another
call
that's the other thing well also if you
got a facetime call
he's a wife so right it's like cheating
that's why he apologized to his wife as
well
got it i mean or maybe he was just like
pulling up a video
on his phone i don't know either way
like it just seems strange to me that
like you know
there's so in quarantine like we're
spending so much time at home there's so
much time to masturbate like why do it
when you're like in the middle of a call
you know yeah
that's kind of weird no it's beyond
weird um
also like if you are gonna masturbate on
a zoom call i would just recommend that
like you are extremely careful about
like making sure your camera and your
microphone
are off maybe like you know i just think
that would be step one well that has
become my favorite tic toc trend is like
college students who are working
remotely like sharing them accidentally
and like not realizing their mic was on
because
when you're in like a zoom with 300
people everyone's mic is supposed to be
off except the teacher
um so like everyone's like probably in
their bedroom like talking to their
friends on their phone like talking to
their parents
and it's so funny to see people who
realize that their mics are on because
it's like
the teacher's assigning homework and
like this girl literally puts her hand
over her eyes and just like
screams into her hands and she didn't
know that her mic was on it's so funny
it's literally my favorite tic toc trend
of like and if that's what comes out of
like
college students having to study from
home like i'm okay with that
yeah but it's also like yeah i've seen
some
where like people go to the bathroom and
yeah well those are [ __ ] disgusting
like i don't want to see that but
kids like when you really think that or
also like i saw this one this morning
where you're all the sorority stuff is
like now being done via zoom like bid
day or whatever i don't know i wasn't in
a sorority
and it was like this girl is on a zoom
and she thinks she's on mute and she's
like sending a snapchat to her friends
and she's like
guys it's like big little association
day like i literally hate my bank
and obviously she was not on zoom in
like her bit she wasn't on mute and her
big literally hurt everything it's so
funny it's
it's a real problem that is fascinating
never experienced it's also sad when no
one turns their mic on like remember
when you're just posting those tick
tocks nature's posting these tick tocks
of like teachers teaching on zoom and
like everybody's camera and mic are off
and the teacher is literally talking to
no one because you know that the kids
aren't paying attention and they're like
so sad
it's so sad i think everything about
like zoom
learning is sad to me and it's like
or you're getting to see someone
masturbate yeah also why are these our
options
not interesting no i agree like why are
these our options these teachers who
like it's probably hard for them to
figure out like the remote learning the
technology their kids are probably
helping them
just to get out of zoom with 300 people
and like literally have nobody respond
to you but like i actually it makes me
want to cry like
it's so sad like if you're a college
student and you listen to this like
every now and then just like go off mute
and be like
okay cool you know like mm-hmm right
yeah like one of those you know yeah
or it should be like mandatory to have
your camera on and then knowing that
your camera's on like try not to
masturbate um
in front of your co-workers it's so sad
i'm like
we gotta get the kids back in school for
the sake of the teachers
yeah for the counselors and for the
campers it's so upsetting like these tic
tacs like they're i think they're meant
to be funny but like is it normal that
i'm in my bed like
sobbing no it's it's so sad it's so sad
um
justice just respect your teachers guys
respect your teachers and respect your
coworkers
and don't masturbate on zoom and don't
mess yeah um
and that those are the fast side stories
that you need to know and i feel as
though
you needed to know them i felt like they
were good like in robust yeah quite
robust
yeah so um there was no tv on so
no tv recap i'm re remiss to let this
show come to an end but i'm remiss said
the show come to an end but our ant
duties like are so important and we're
really so excited but oh the show's not
coming the show is not coming to an end
because we have a special interview
um right after this for our podcast
listeners if you're watching on youtube
head over to the podcast because we're
talking to craig conover
from southern charm he's such a nice boy
i love him so much like
and his sewing company like really took
off we talked a lot about it
um and i actually feel like he's getting
justice because when he started sewing
like everyone made fun of him like his
friends the show
like andy like it was like a joke and
now he's like a legit partnership he's
like a whole line of merch
and i'm really happy for him so it's
really interesting to hear him talk
about like the comeuppance of summing
down south and as
craig stands like from the beginning
it's it feels nice for us too
it's like what's the word is it
retribution no it's like vindication
something like that yes you know what we
like to call it
justice that there's only one word like
i don't know why we're circling the
drain
plane of justice so enjoy
our interview with craig conover and
we'll see you tomorrow for humpty will
be recording the bachelorette actually
tomorrow oh sorry it wasn't today
and for hump day we can confirm theo
will be in studio
thank the lord thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we are
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so spotify itunes
stitcher public radio ihop radio cast
box
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcast find us morning toast and leave
a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we're also available on amazon
music now that they have podcasts
just wanted to let you guys know that
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast and we hope you have a
great day we'll see you tomorrow goodbye